with the lord of the rings the rings of
power fast approaching tolkien fans may
be wondering what else the future has in
store for the author's legendary
universe a young aragorn series a
spin-off in the shire keep watching for
all this and more
back in 2018 when the rings of power was
still in the early days of
pre-production tolkien fansite the
onering.net reported that the series
would open its first season centered on
a young aragorn in a subsequent tweet
thread the site suggested that aragorn's
story could easily feature such
characters as arwyn gandolf elrond and
even gollum obviously it has since
become clear that the onering.net were
way off the mark but they were right
about one thing the adventures of young
aragorn would make for a fantastic
television series much of the future
king of gondor's early life is told in
the appendices of the lord of the rings
in these stories aragorn journeys into
the wilderness as chieftain of the
dunadine befriends gandalf the grey and
serves the king of rohan and the steward
of gondor in their struggles against
mordor he also travels into the
mysterious regions in the east and south
of middle-earth and attempts to track
down gollum after his disappearance from
misty mountains perhaps most importantly
of all though he meets and falls in love
with arwen undomio the daughter of the
elf lord elrond as far as plot material
goes it doesn't get much more bountiful
than this aragorn's quests through
middle-earth prior to the lord of the
rings would prove the basis for multiple
seasons worth of television or streaming
series it doesn't exactly hurt either
that amazon studios happens to
reportedly own the rights to the
appendices in which they're contained in
the extended edition of peter jackson's
return of the king gimli laments to
legolas that he can't call on his fellow
dwarves to join the royal rim on their
march to gondor legolas replies
your kinsmen may have no need to write a
war
i fear war already marches on their own
lands
this is a reference to an incident that
only appears in the appendices to the
lord of the rings the battle of dale
this monumentally important conflict
takes place concurrently with the siege
of ministerith and the battle of the
pelanor fields the two-week-long
confrontation finds an army of men and
dwarves led by king brand of dale and
dane ironfoot fighting against sauron's
easterlings in the course of the battle
both brand and dane are killed but their
successors managed to prevent the
easterlings from breaking through
towards gondor after the ring is
destroyed they finally drive the enemy
from their lands both dale and erebor
have already been depicted in live
action in all three hobbit movies but
the battle of dale has yet to warrant
anything more than a brief mention in a
single deleted scene still this savage
confrontation is rife with drama from
brand and dane's last stand at the gate
of airbor to the darkest hours of the
easterling siege to the final push to
free the mountain and its people newline
cinema is currently gearing up to
release an anime feature film about the
life of helm hammerhead the legendary
king of rohan and if the studio is
indeed eyeing an anime-based future for
their middle-earth stories they could do
much worse than an adaptation of the
battle of dale ask any token fan for the
one chapter in middle earth's history
they'd like to see adapted into live
action and there's a pretty solid chance
they'll say
the angmar war again this story appears
almost solely within the appendices to
the lord of the rings this war is fought
between the forces of agmar led by the
witch king and the manish kingdom of
arnor and it takes place over the course
of some 600 years during the mid-third
age the conflict engulfs the region of
eriador in northwestern middle earth
bringing together men and elves from
every corner of the world to stand
against sauron's chief servant but
before the end of the war arnor itself
has been almost entirely annihilated
though the free peoples do eventually
defeat the witch king and force him to
flee to parts unknown in fact it's after
the final great confrontation of the war
the battle of the fornost that the elf
lord glorfendell infamously prophesizes
that no man will kill the witch king and
you probably know how that turns out
i am no man
[Music]
the angmar war is one of the darkest and
most brutal conflicts in the history of
the third age while this narrative is
marked by death disease and destruction
it also exhibits the same sense of hope
and unity that the lord of the rings
does so well
obviously no single movie could possibly
capture the sheer scale of the witch
king's finest hour but a long form
series would be another matter entirely
otherwise known as the asari the five
angelic mayar who come to middle-earth
as wizards play extraordinarily
important roles in the fight against
sauron these five wizards are saruman
the white gandalf the gray radagast the
brown and the two blue wizards alatar
and palundo you probably know how things
play out with saruman and gandalf the
former allows his ambition to get the
better of him falling into darkness
before his own lackey unceremoniously
assassinates him the latter well is
gandalf isn't he you
shall not
pass
ratagas meanwhile settles down near
mirkwood for much of the third age
befriending the birds and beasts of the
forest and keeping an eye on the growing
shadow in dolgodur in the books he
inadvertently leads gandalf in saruman's
trap before helping him escape and then
pretty much vanishes from middle-earth
altogether the blue wizards venture
eastwards to either disrupt sauron's
plans or establish their own magical
cults depending on which of tolkien's
writings you take as gospel saruman
gandolf and radogast arrive in middle
earth around the year 1000 of the third
age while the blue wizards possibly show
up sometime in the second age this means
that the astari have been roaming for at
least 2 000 years before frodo embarks
on his quest thanks to tolkien's
reticence on their history readers have
only their imaginations to suggest what
they might have been doing during that
time perhaps a spin-off of some kind
following the wizards on their
adventures in the mortal world could
shed some light on the matter the story
of the kingdom of kazadoom is long
glorious and
dark
literally best known as the setting for
some of the most iconic moments in the
fellowship of the ring moria once housed
a thriving dwarvish realm that stretched
far beneath the deep reaches of the
misty mountains during the first and
second ages of middle earth the history
of kazudum is one of peace prosperity
and expansion even during the turbulent
days of the late second age these
dwarves avert the ravages of war by
shutting their gates and cutting
themselves off from the outside world
everything changes however during the
third age in the year ta 1980 the
dwarves obsessively mining the stores of
mithril contained within the mountain
accidentally awaken a balrog
shadow
and flame
king duran vi is killed during the
demon's rampage earning it the name
durian's bane and the surviving dwarves
flee their once great kingdom the
dwarves attempt to retake moria a couple
of times over the next few hundred years
but it isn't until the coming of during
the seventh over 170 years after the
events of the lord of the rings that
they finally succeed
the rise fall and rise again of the
greatest dwarvish kingdom is a tragic
and terrifying saga but one that also
goes overlooked by many of tolkien's
readers
no doubt it would provide ample
opportunity for a filmmaker to explore a
darker more horrific side of the
author's world and give the dwarves of
middle-earth some much-needed attention
in the process
the fall of moria briefly intertwines
with another stage in the long journey
of tolkien's dwarves one that would be
equally gripping as its own adaptation
fans have actually glimpsed a
live-action portrayal of the wars of the
dwarves and orcs before the climactic
battle of azernold tsar appears in a
flashback in the hobbit an unexpected
journey but there's a whole lot more to
this desperate struggle between dwarf
and dork the war begins when moria's orc
chieftain azod kills thor the exiled
king under the mountain thrower's son
thrain marches toward to avenge his
fallen father amassing a great army of
dwarves from all across middle earth the
dwarves blunder and pillaged down the
breath of the misty mountains tolkien
writes
both sides were pitiless and there was
death and cruel deeds by dark and by
light after six years of warfare much of
which takes place underground the two
sides clash outside the east gate of
morya in what is later known as the
battle of azinul bazar here dane
ironfoot kills azog and the orcs are
routed though they stop short of
entering moria for fear of joran's bane
worse still the vengeance of the dwarves
comes at a terrible cost and countless
dwarvish lives are lost during this
final battle while the war of the
dwarves and dorics might only constitute
one part of a wider moria project it
could easily stand as its own story and
particularly one for fans of the hobbit
movies a spin-off film or series set
within the boundaries of the shire could
take almost any form it might offer a
pleasant and comedic exploration of the
lives of hobbits during peace time the
stakes needn't be higher than a drunken
expedition to farmer maggot's crop or a
dispute over an elderly relative's
inheritance it could go a little darker
too perhaps bringing the scouring of the
shire to the big screen for the first
time to really show the hobbits in a
brand new light however you'd have to
turn to the war between the hobbits and
orcs that ends with the battle of
greenfields a few hundred years before
the lord of the rings bands of orcs from
the misty mountains invade eriador while
the dunadine rangers managed to keep
most of them at bay one group led by the
goblin king golfenball successfully
enters the shire led by bando brass took
the hobbits meet the orcs in a battle at
the greenfields when took a decapitates
golfing bull and sends his head flying
into a nearby rabbit hole the battle is
won in the game of golf invented at the
same time
in so many of tolkien's stories war is
shown to be very much the province of
men elves dwarves and orcs a short
series animation or even a film that
sees vanderbrass and his hobbits rise up
to defend their homeland would shine a
whole new light on the shire and its
inhabitants
during his lifetime j.r tolkien composed
three stories set during the quentus and
marillion that were written to be
enjoyed as complete works in and of
themselves found in the silmarillion
these stories did not require the reader
to have an understanding of the wider
mythos they are known as the three great
tales of the elder days of middle earth
and by far the most famous of them all
is the tale of baron and luthien
otherwise known as the quest for the
silmaril the narrative revolves around
the forbidden romance between baron a
man and luthien the daughter of the elf
king thingol when their love is exposed
an enraged thingal jokingly promises
that baron will be allowed to marry
luthien if he enters morgoth's fortress
of angband plucks a sacred jewel from
his crown and brings it back to the
elves of doriath to his surprise baron
agrees quickly setting out to fulfill
his task the story was very dear to
tolkien's heart on his gravestone he is
named as baron while his beloved wife
edith is named as luthien perhaps that's
why the tale of baron and luthien
arguably feels like the author's finest
work swathed in the near palpable
passion and devotion he clearly felt
towards his world what happened to her
she died
certainly the lay of lathian an
incomplete poetic rendition of the tale
contains some of his most beautiful and
affecting writing no part of tolkien's
vast legendarium is more deserving of a
faithful adaptation
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you